[Music]
in the let it all out news submitted by
watch out Bart what yeah that's you
congressman Eric swallow yeah okay nice
ripping a massive part live on MSNBC
denies not who did this you don't do not
cover it up with the sneeze you don't
deny it I know I said it or did this no
no he's a congressman California trying
to cover up his young but his fart this
guy I didn't yawn I farted this guy is
the most dentist looking [ __ ]
I've ever seen in my life
like white dentist white dentist oh wait
till you see this guy's you see them all
he's like my chair squeaked hashtag fart
gate so he was talking about the like
the current you guys look like a dentist
right let me clean your teeth yeah yeah
yeah yes
oh well taxpayer dollars to ask the
premiums to help them cheat he pause
because it rippled his ass cheeks have
made a bounce so much that he was like
soon you don't know if it [ __ ] if it's
gonna be like a fart and you thought it
was gonna be small and it came out
really big pushed and even like those
are farts through slacks it would I
wasn't like an area you were right that
was like check his pants after that one
is he trying to cover it up
what is he blaming it on that Lee
oh let's ask the cat interview the
cameraman he's miked up here by the way
what if it's someone that was a rapper
wait convectional - yeah did you see on
his face yeah what if it's the person
that was calling in so like you know how
they doing
now on to you whatever anything goes
it's happening it was in an interview
with MSNBC host Chris Matthews he's the
guy that farted baracy they're like is
it Chris or is it Eric why did Eric
react because Chris is known for like
party but he paused Hugh Pardo so this
is Chris picture dude looks like he's
putting in this modem he looks like he
supplied it one with the little whoopee
cushion probably in the bathroom like he
looks like he'd dude that he looks fine
so there are rumors looks like he
actually pardon that there's a rumor
that he's was very well known in the
studio to be a farter so the people are
like was it Chris
or was it Eric cuz it clearly looks like
[ __ ] Eric didn't play it again they
make people said NBA's and [ __ ] that no
one could speak about it look watch his
face it's just eyebrows to put it you
you kind of tenses in like put it on
silence and we can say when you hard can
we do it on a sound in the shoulders you
see him come on you know yeah you gotta
greet the bottom why can't here's the
thing why can't he just say yeah I'm
gonna give me my fart so he acts
okay so how did he deny it I want to see
the denial you know I'm saying that like
girls don't poop is that they don't you
know girls are the stinky [ __ ] has ever
seen a butt cave
okay a BuzzFeed reporter ended up
sending him a DM on Twitter and said I'm
really sorry about this but I have to
ask if this was you or someone in the
studio so he responded with it was not
me with five exclamation mark that's
obstruction of justice and then he goes
huh
and I didn't hear it when I was speaking
and then the reporter says you look like
you heard it and are stifling a laugh
and he says I definitely did not hear it
is that the follow-up conversation she
got he got called up right right there
he got called out after his speech did
you just bark so I said she sent him a
Twitter oh they'll be funny if that was
the following after they just
disregarded anything that he said
they're like did you just fart no that
was that was that was not me that was
not me I don't know who did that was it
like if we recall Eric swallow for
farting on the air is that possible can
you recall you guys blow my [ __ ] mind
sometimes I got it I know you did but
you didn't have my back
you did that excuse ad they're holding
max you're going I try to explain that's
fine no I recall moving on we're not
moving on it was just a bit I don't even
want to talk about it's a Total Recall
right you got okay so hardball the show
tweeted sorry to dissapoint the
conspiracy theorist it was the heart
hashtag hardball mug scraping across the
desk today and let's get back to the
news smart and then the Chris the guy
that we're all talking about here that
farted sure he ended up like retweeting
this and saying like Hasse I forgot
what'd he say I farted it copy that but
in all caps total exoneration we don't
believe the media I don't believe I
don't believe it because I don't believe
that aspects he killed himself here no I
don't hear no fart sound
that's how like OFC didn't kill himself
that's right that's what it sounds like
to me hey all I know is that ABC News
sure didn't mind covering that up but I
guess I guess NBC's farmers know though
even bite actually did an experiment
because they're like okay what kind of
desk is in the studio right now this so
as of last year and as of a recent
instagrams hugs I mean in the glass
daesil and they got laid in actual mud
that's similar to the one they're
blaming it on and did all these tests or
like and anything cut those sound waves
of the [ __ ] at the [ __ ] test and
they're like no if only they cared about
this much about the Epstein cover-up you
know you can tell that I don't talk
about poly it's not even politics it's
just [ __ ] it all sounds the same
sometimes it's it's a mean it's a mean
and it's a kind of scorn unquote
conspiracy theory well but it's not
really a conspiracy when the doctor came
out and said that he was not he was
murdered you and Joe Rogan says it all
the time
yep well anyway well nothing a glass
table and check out those bugs makes the
no I'm glad they're talking about some
real news and not Prince Albert what was
it what was he even talking about again
cuz I don't even know what is that
thanks Albert likes to [ __ ] kids yes
because it's a Blake Nicki blade would
you like them doing this I'll just talk
my username that Nicki axes so I decided
this he did that one though in case it
like real no I have the real bird has it
this is not real this is the most
floppiest knife I've ever saw from here
look at that I mean I don't know I don't
know what type of show y'all run so
could have been real I don't know it's a
prop knife it's cute
thank you do you believe the news no see
I don't know anyone in our generation
that does okay
I work in radio there's a big part of
stuff that I see sometimes I'm like
that's wrong and you'll read like
multiple stories a lot of it is like I
deal with a lot of stuff in like hip-hop
and things along those lines that you
know most of it's fake so imagine if
they're lying on those what they're
probably doing behind the scenes on a
lot of some other fake stuff you read
damn near everything like a lot I don't
like gossip news oh I know parts
I don't like it because I could only
imagine like having to deal with it one
day yeah oh so you don't want to be a
part of that no I just think about one
day i'ma have to sit with that person
and if I go and I talk [ __ ] and I go and
bring up something I know I remember who
used to talk [ __ ] about me so you're so
nice I'm not I just want to be in a
situation don't you want to talk some
[ __ ] and then be like oh let's clear it
up and you can sit down if I do yeah
if I believe it there's some stories we
were like yeah you know they did it you
know he slept with her yeah like he
parted yeah right he did why are you
denying it let's have mr. slopes wall
well on here and let's let's have a
conversation about the real [ __ ] and
while we're talking to him we can put
fart noises the whole time but imagine
if he said yes I did it it would be over
right over but since he's denying it
we're talking about it huh it's like oh
you know all the times like with the sex
tape videos and everybody else coming
out with something if you own up to it
and you own it it goes way faster yeah
it could be part of this campaign to
vote for me remember the one that farted
[Music]
me I'm the one that didn't fart oh you
see now you're a liar sex tapes are
different though because if I watch your
sex tape I saw you being hot or whatever
be known as the fart guys a lot
different you know I'm saying like like
you're known and said instead of being
known as like a sexy person your husband
farty dude so you lie about it now you
look like you're stupid you lied about
farting oh yeah he does look stupid
you've never mind about party what do
you mean all the time maybe I should
live one relationship you know it is
that was not me it didn't do it if you
didn't hear it it wasn't me here you're
a big believer in don't fart around
people right I try not to yeah we talked
about you ever fart in a elevator and
you got to run out but then you forgot
that yet to get something again you run
back to the elevator and you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] why did I farted here not
often yeah okay that's happened before
you have oh yeah big regrets big regret
you don't fart uh not around my lady
ever let around your friends
man I respect that what about do you let
the sound get too
No thank you thank you we have a rule
right we have a role where I can't fart
around here so I'm not cool
so now I go somewhere else to go far no
he does it I do I go somewhere else to
go find out you do know Bart you can
hear it through the walls so I'll go for
it here like I don't know what the do
part for example I my mother would have
killed me if I ever spit in front of a
woman you know how you spit on the
sidewalk my mom wouldn't [ __ ] kill me
so I have a thing even if I'm walking in
the morning whatever and this car is
going by
I have to look in the car see if it's a
lady and if I don't see one for a sec I
can spit what do you need a spit I've
never had to spit you know you don't
believe in gender equality I guess no no
no I don't I only don't spin families no
you know you don't you know I'm a guy
who guys have to spit a lot that means
your mom never dating a cowboy I played
softball so for some reason I don't know
like you do actually not I'm thinking
about it I have nope maybe there's just
excess [ __ ] in my mouth and I have to
get it out yeah sometimes yeah you just
have dust from the softball game or
anything are you eating my dad used to
tell me not to eat sunflower seeds
because I should is disgusting like
spitting it out and I was like hmm yeah
it is kind of gross but barbecue
sunflower seeds are really good I like
the ranch wine oh those are good two
years or dill dill so Bart point being
if you do something that your woman can
see or hear it is the same as doing it
yes thank you
Oh was I supposed to know that her ears
so good hear my own fart your walls are
echoey though what about going to the
bathroom which is what I did dad or
turning on the sink okay no not just
that
what if you don't spray anything after
and then you go in it oh that pisses
Mel's I don't care about sounds like
while you're here bother me where I'm
like yeah
I'm not [ __ ] laughing yeah but if I
walk in you're near that area and I
smell it I would be pissed on my
beautiful can courtesy flush you mean
consider the rest of the people in this
house it's pretty gross oh yeah yeah a
long-term relationship literally was so
it like I can hear it I would go like I
can hear you pee I can hear you pooping
and I'd say that and be like you okay we
good
like first there's certain things that
don't bother me like the bathroom
situation doesn't really blow the
hearing is okay with you okay just don't
like don't do it on purpose like don't
poop on me on purpose
the worst is when you're sleeping and
there's a little poop and your ass is up
and they're sleeping or like Siri
seriously on my leg yeah wee bit pooped
on her late poot I was like wow they do
it different in the Bay Area
there's toggle words I don't like saying
like heart just sounds weird to me
incoming on my scalp I say see that's
why I call it cute no [ __ ] it
somewhere when you said it don't say it
please don't say it it's worried about
her yeah
[Music]
[Music]